hey kitty kitties all right do me a
favor i want you to come see me live i'm
finally touring again all the tickets
are on savile countercomedy.com
many more dates will be added you guys
are always screaming at me the dates
they're going to keep being added but
these are the cities i'll be at uh if we
haven't done it yet right december yeah
this is airing thursday december 4th and
5th i'll be at the west palm beach
improv december 10th in boston the chevy
year theater december 11th at the
borgata kind of hometown thing atlantic
city new jersey there's only a few
tickets left for boston ac please get
those to come out december 26 dallas
december 27 san antonio december 28th
sugarland aka houston december 29th st
louis december 30th columbus and new
year's eve december 31st cincinnati all
those are with chris d and then my new
data just went up january 14th in des
moines january 15th in indianapolis
january 16th in cleveland january 29th
at foxwoods in connecticut we are adding
a show the first one is basically sold
out february 19th in washington dc
tysons virginia to be announced very
quickly uh
next week or this coming week i will be
announcing just so keep a heads up san
diego los angeles burlington vermont
detroit pittsburgh albany madison and
chicago all tickets savolcano comedy.com
uh more cities being announced i mean
it's a mouthful but i just i need you
guys to come out and see me because it's
been so long and we need to laugh and uh
this is casey jost everybody the earth
is
flat talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
foods gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
buds
sally babe he doesn't know about that he
only watches i know i only watched the
clips i didn't know about the yelling
right off the bat
i didn't know
about a dozen episodes ago and uh he's
sticking with it oh i like it the fans
like it yeah the fans like it i'm
sticking with it
there's new merch coming out no matter
what happens i love you merch when is it
among other things i had a big meeting
yesterday we're looking for maybe in a
week or two oh okay drop it like it's
hot yeah tons of archery all right great
that merch will be available through
something we're gonna have an online
store yeah an online store as you do
uh
good to see you yes uh like to welcome
our
second guest ever a lovely friend
hysterical comedian uh joe list well
this will air before the
no no no because sam's episode is going
to air after this one
because this feels good this is holiday
related i moved up in the order
yeah so joe you're chronologically our
third guest but second guest in the
airing order yeah it's like abby road
nothing better than jumping over a guest
that's a good feel it's a good start it
gives me a little confidence [ __ ] sam
roberts
you want to tell us a little about
yourself joe not particularly
i don't know i'm a comedian and i love
the show but i've never listened to the
show it's all i'm the clips i'm a clip
guy yeah but to be fair i don't listen
to podcasts if i listen to podcasts you
guys would would joe list
to the top of the order but what's going
on with the hat i just put on a hat oh
all right
um
i'm just using it as it was meant what
did you just say every clip is a verb
well i'm saying i jumped sam roberts oh
look at this this is the level of
professionalism look look at this he's
still eating i i get it well my god
almighty i'm similar i can't get rid of
the same i can't just wrap up a meal
with this food left i don't understand
those people
and we started you started the show
before he was done with his body i just
love the sandwich the state of the
sandwich that he's eating with a zero
sugar vitamin water next to it
i mean this thing's got mayonnaise on it
it's got chips on it it's got ham
sandwiches yeah what's fun is that
listen it looks like a nice sandwich i
just i like the juxtaposition i like
that you crinkled the foil with the
microphone pointing at the foil to
really
really get in the eardrums of everybody
i like the it was a funny juxtaposition
huh or contradict i should say right
oh boy
sometimes those noises can make me like
chalkboard
this is that new thing now where people
like
meditate or or masturbate to that
something they don't know they do
something to sound straight menstruating
it's a big thing now write the sounds
yeah people love the sounds right
what do they do though is to sue them or
does it turn them on buddy i don't know
what you're talking about amsr it's i
didn't understand asmr but then i read
about it and i realized i've known about
my whole life it's like if you ever talk
to somebody like a doctor that talks
like this and they're really paying
attention to you it's susie and you can
feel almost like uh hi
is that right is that what they're
getting from it i don't know if it's
like high but it's like a feeling where
you kind of come out of yeah similar to
a high it's like a high all right yeah
someone's like i really like your
glasses joe you know what i mean yeah
yeah like oh i should start doing that
to go to sleep because i go to sleep
every night to audio books and it's i'm
having a hard time with it i think i
just need to start going to sleep to
like one of these voices
i go i fall asleep by listening to your
album
i used to go to sleep to stand up albums
that i like though oh you know who does
this joe pera
ah
joe perry was the head of this game joe
para talks you to sleep that was a show
he did really he speaks very soothing
yes he does tomatoes and stuff he does
speak soon cracks me up that kid about
tomatoes yeah yeah what'd you say about
tomato he's a real he's a real big
tomato fan
he almost talks a lot of times
exclusively about about tomatoes he's a
real big tomato he's obsessed with
tomatoes really yeah you know what are
you just just telling me no no i know
about it i don't i never watched the
program but i know it's he's tomato
based
he loves tomatoes what is the um what is
it you gotta love when a guy calls you
three times in a row and you keep
declining the call and he just keeps
calling do you worry about that he's
still what he's saying on the other end
right you got to love when you call
someone three times in a row and they
just keep declining fourth call who is
fourth ball in a row gino bisconte
that's the fourth call in a row i'm i'm
i want to take it on aaron because i'm
doing it i'm working because unlike yeah
anything can happen unlike you i respect
what we're doing well you got your phone
face up with the vibrator on you've
picked it up on airplane mode in the
pocket you might need to go to it for a
reference i might need to look stuff up
television today so we've been going to
the phones
from gino bisconte
that's far too many
you really had a negative reaction to
this
i always think of biscotti when you say
his name yeah because it's so similar
well by the way i like gino but i
thought it was like an aunt or a sister
like it might be a no situation i would
have thought maybe i gotta pick it up
it's right
i mean look if gino's calling me for
help he's [ __ ] out of luck cause i love
the guy but i won't be there for him no
you know i love the guy but i won't be
there for him
i love the guy but i won't be there
there's your merch
yeah i love you but i won't be there for
you wow well speaking of that uh let's
get in here you're gonna learn this one
we gotta do this before we start every
battle what happened so what happened
you only watched the clip so you may not
know it unless you did actually there
was a clip a few weeks ago that
showcased this oh interesting
joe brought three chants to the table
recently that we have to do that for me
they feel sophomoric but i've grown to
love them i see and and and people and
and people didn't didn't [ __ ] on them
they actually loved there's only a
couple of people squeaky wheels that are
like stopped a chance most people like i
love the chance i love the chance so he
went home one day very depressed from
from a tough battle no joke that's your
drawers for you and uh sometimes we get
sometimes we get so happy it's a lot of
flame before the battle coming sometimes
we get so happy i prefer you in the
battles am i and you're if we're keeping
track you're like nine and two in my
opinion thank you thank you we've had 54
episodes but i like you better as a
person okay
all right guys
most people don't like me in either
category sometimes we get so heated that
joe will call me or text me afterward
and go are we good or and i say we're
100 good joe it's just a
podcast show you know tape value and he
says well i was talking to my mother and
she doesn't know if we're good either
and i said well you tell i'm talking to
you straight up we're good
so then one day he told me he came in
and he goes i i want us to do something
before each battle and it'll kind of set
the tone so we know to not go overboard
and really feel something inside and uh
this is what we do and
so should he join in or should we just
watch i'll i'm like i'm a warrior all
right we're gonna get ready to do
today's battle
actually let me announce today's battle
first uh you saw it in the title folks
you may know it from the title of the
clip
we are doing
excuse me
it's a little soda gas we're doing uh
in honor of the thanksgiving season mac
and cheese versus stuffing and this is
the first ever once again on this show
it is me versus sal
and our guest joe list they are both
team mac and cheese oh yeah first ever
because it was me and you were sorry
yeah
yeah and i'm i'm stuffing that doesn't
make more sense right yeah yeah like the
okay uh you're stuffing i'm stuffing
yeah oh i thought i was stuffing no i'm
stuffing your mac and cheese would list
oh well because we switched it rude we
were gonna talk bread and butter yeah we
were gonna do bread and butter yeah and
then i said let's do mac and cheese
versus stuffing i said you two can do
mac and cheese and i'll take stuffing
and you said okay oh i thought because i
said to you
i said to you what's the powerhouse
pimp am i crazy pimp you were here for
all of it well
no i know but you said you could take
back and chill what are we going to do
what are we going to do here
you could pick a team
then we got to go stuffing against joe
are you prepared
mac and cheese are this stuffing is [ __ ]
of course i'm prepared okay i didn't
prepare but but it feels weird to have
the buddies as a guest because the guest
is already going to be the least
favorite ari went against us no it's
fine they're voting
all right ready here we go ready
here we go
anymore we're on the same team
oh yeah i guess we don't have to do it
because we have to learn a chance no you
know what let me jump on joe's side
all right
he's back on your team i'm gonna jump on
joe's side all right great
all right ready here we go
here we go all right yeah sure
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you oh i did see
that yeah yeah right i didn't care for
it it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e butts all right okay here we
go um
i love that you saw the the sadness and
fear in my eyes that you had to jump
back onto my team i appreciate it but
certainly you do like mac and cheese
more than stuffing well here we go
here's what i believe
day to day i would choose mac that's why
i went came back over on a day to day
every day i take mac and cheese over
stuffing but stuffing is so high on my
list because i have it so infrequently
that if i'm really thinking about how
often i have stuffing in my real world
experience stuffing beats mac and cheese
if you put two on the table say which
one do you want i would choose stuffing
because i don't have stuffing often
i'm one of the guys that falls into a
camp stuffy should be a year-round food
just like i think christmas lights
should be up all year long
i don't know what to tell you
the bottom line is that stuffing is not
year-round and especially not the good
stuffing i'm not talking stovetop and
i'm not taking a dump on stovetop
because i know people love stovetop but
i know stovetop is an admirable
replacement from time to time it's on
the go
grand slam i mean let's go stovetop is
bread crumbs with water that you heat up
in a microwave yeah and it tastes
amazing that's fine i'm talking about
your grandma's recipe your aunt's recipe
yeah you know i'm talking about that i'm
going to go all day long on stuffing i'm
i'm ready yeah but i'm talking about
something i'll give you an example i
have a an aunt
okay she makes stuffing with chopped
meat and olives
i have my my stepmom she makes chopped
meat with raisins uh she makes stuffing
with raisins there's different types of
stuffing and i'm talking about those
homegrown
yeah both of your ants are disgusting
yeah this is horrible they're delicious
they're delicious babe meat and and
what'd you say olives yeah
you don't put meat and olive next to
each other everybody knows
stuffing and it works you put a piece of
bologna in your martini no that'd be
ridiculous yeah your aunt like your
aunt's the bartender if she made bloody
marys or be like the slider on it and
everything you're like this is too much
what are you doing what i'm talking
about though is i'm just making a case
for for me
i think you're gonna you're i know you
and you're gonna be your typical self
and you're gonna argue with stove top
well you should be arguing for
home-grown stuffing
stuffing i'm saying don't start taking
shots at stovetop the leading
the only brand of instance that should
tell you anybody's even if it's an
over-the-counter instant stuffing you're
not going to cook a bird for a day and a
half and baste it and soak it and get up
at 6 00.
[Music]
over-the-counter
at thanksgiving you're going homemade
stuffing but for somebody like you that
is an advocate for year-round stuffing
you're gonna need that stovetop no he's
missing my point completely i'm
advocating for people to cook homegrown
stuffing all year long you take it
because you don't have to do it you see
me 11 months
to do it out of the year stove top
versus mac and cheese mac and cheese
takes a big cheesy dumpling yeah but you
don't on youtube here's why here's what
i hate about your argument you don't
have to do it you got 16 ants making
goofy olive stuffings all over the map
you're relying on other people to make
your stuffing for you if it was up to
you you'd be a stovetop you are the guy
you are the guy that still makes
stovetop
you've been late
you're halfway through your life and
you're still getting the dollar 19
stuffing sometimes upgrade your life
sometimes learn a recipe i make stuffing
from scratch too i'm saying i love all
of this what's your stuffing got from
scratch mr stuffing celery
carrots
you saute a chopped carrot i've never
looked down at a pile of second-rate
vegetables and thought this is going in
this stuff you finally changing
what i mean
where's the main portion what's the main
point red and then there's all kinds of
seasonings that go in and then sometimes
i add a sausage
sausage you just i just told you she put
meat in it you just want to you can
rewind the tape you [ __ ] listen to the
difference you just went listen she said
oh she'd put a slider no no bloody man
listen to the difference between what i
said versus what you said i put a
sausage in a stuffing sometimes you said
chopped meat
that meant disgusting i meant me this
wouldn't know no i don't know what you
meant what is what does it mean tell me
what it means what i'm sorry i'm sorry
sorry sorry sausage is sausages
a1 and some version of a of a of of a
seasoned chopped meat sure it is off the
recipe do you ever have a sausage and
stuffing it's unbelievable okay great
okay meat is meat in the stuffing
you made it sound like she put [ __ ] in a
stuffing that doesn't belong
well that is how i felt the obviously
we're all the same tea yes okay the
olives do not belong but a meat and a
stuffing is fine you would think you
didn't that's why it's a very bespoke
personality on the meat i sometimes i'll
add a cranberry to a stuffing
can i just i don't want to be a bad
guest and end the episode right here
because i feel like i'm going to say
something that's just going to end the
episode we're gonna have to come up with
a new category okay no 12 year old boy
comes home from middle school latch key
kid and goes i'm hungry let me make some
stuffing
well we are on the same team but i will
tell you that that was stovetop's entire
campaign thank you very much
boy coming home from school and his
friend came home from school and they
were both having stovetop and they both
got invited to each other's house for
stove top stuffing at different times so
they could both double up on the stove
you're switching
i'm sorry i shouldn't speak for
everybody but i'm a normal human being
american boy i went to baseball practice
i came home my parents weren't home
because they didn't care about me so i
boiled up some kraft mac and cheese
delicious home alone kevin mcallister
doesn't make stuffing i will agree with
you that i will agree with you that if
you're you know college dorm lifestyle
kid after school latch all that stuff
it's it's it you're not cooking a box of
stove jobs and just eating it i could do
that i've not usually lived alone for
years and i've done it i put it in a big
tupperware i heated up all at once and i
ate it uh it's the only thing i cooked
and i ate at intervals during the night
so i had some at eight nine ten eleven
and by the end of the night or the next
day i had the whole stovetop you are
stuffing you don't even know what team
you're on you're arguing with both sides
you've got meeting you you've got to
sell around
what's happening 20 though he's 45.
yeah he's wait but he's well into the
second half of life yeah i make stuffing
from scratch i also sometimes make
stovetop i like both look i make
hamburgers from scratch i also sometimes
like mcdonald's you can like bubble
this is a mcdonald's reference 54
episodes running folks you can like both
versions of a thing i know and i'll tell
you right now uh a homemade mac and
cheese if we bring that to the table
i mean you're done please you're done
please let me tell you we'll tell you
let me know
let me say something i had to let me see
something right now
nobody in the history of humanity has
ever
successfully made a homemade mac and
cheese it is fresh for five minutes and
it it becomes a brick in that in that
casserole heat it back up oh it stinks
it's got all the hard pieces on the edge
it's terrible okay joe's making a great
point right now i think i feel like yeah
and some people actually put like a
stuffing on top of their homemade
homemade mac and cheese does suck but
kraft and panera bread i'm a basic [ __ ]
those are better than any stuffing ever
but i do agree when someone brings out a
homemade mac and cheese i i frown sucks
i get nervous i used to work in a
delicate city and i and i worked behind
it and i made all the things i made the
meatloaf i made the rice balls i made
their meatballs and i made the mac and
cheese and i was taught it by an old
woman who made the deli before me and
she had a homemade recipe and i used to
make a tray of it and i used to cut four
different types of cheese into cubes and
mix it all together and at the end she
had a golden brown beautiful breaded
buttered uh crumb on top like a
breadcrumb that she coated the whole top
with and used to cut it like a piece of
cake and it was one of our biggest
sellers you just gotta find someone who
makes it right you're telling me and we
all just established you're no you're in
the twilight years of your life you're
telling me
your entire life you've never had a
single
good homemade mac and cheese i'm not a
huge mac and cheese guy to begin with
but i will tell you this when it moves
into homemade territory i'm far less of
a fan i i i can't remember a time where
i've had it where it wasn't
either too dense too crunchy
too
too stringy because the people don't
know how to make the cheese sauce
properly right like cheese sauce
mac and cheese isn't it
it's not mac and cheese sauce it's mac
and cheese no you have to add you have
to do something with the cheese where
you add milk to cream it up a bit you
you can't just put shredded cheese into
a mac and cheese call it mac and cheese
that doesn't work i just don't ever call
it cheese sauce i'm sorry that's that's
what that's that's what you make that
feels more like a dip
for a tortilla you create a cheese sauce
that can then you know it's it's it's
saucy yeah it's a saucy dish it's like
when people don't do that they just
throw cheese in it you pull it out it's
all string it's gross that's melted
cheese it's not like a strawberry i'm
saying it's good
homemade mac and cheese you get a craft
out of the box
or maybe some of your higher ends you
know hamburger helper i believe dipped
into mac and cheese what about
stouffer's and gophers
and he's very nice
also the makers of stuff white cheddar
thank you very much
well yeah i think that's yeah stouffer's
yeah i've never heard of a stove that's
not that's not oh that's the frozen one
that's for [ __ ] what frozen one that's
orange sofas frozen oh you lift a little
lid on the side and you get some hair
if you close your eyes and put it in
your mouth you would know you were
eating something that was edible you
wouldn't be able to identify as much i
have no idea who's on what side on this
map it's everything for himself
today it was night i have remained good
i everybody
i don't know what's going on
[Laughter]
howdy folks joe derosa here to talk to
you about one of our favorite sponsors
butcher box uh and i am actually i
apologize that this is not the normal
look of uh of our ads but i'm actually
at work
in my new sandwich shop and restaurant
i'm upstairs in our little office and i
can't think of a more appropriate place
to be talking to you about butcher box
because what i'm trying to do with my
joey rose's location is bring people
food that's delicious and affordable
conveniently and that's what booster box
butcher box does for the nation they
bring it right to your door quality
quality meets very very affordably and
efficiently it's what everybody needs
right now these are grass-fed beefs
there's no antibiotics or or hormones in
any of this stuff each box contains
between 8 to 14 pounds of meat for god's
sakes people it's coming right to your
door the healthiest version of the meat
and it's affordable why would you not do
this i love butcher box i really mean it
and i'm going to read you this part just
to make sure i don't mess it up the
holiday butcher box special
all right this is what i'm giving you
right now butcher pox is proud to give
you
new members
free new york strip steaks for a year
what
i love steak personally i love it it's
my favorite
uh
cut of meat and the shrimp is my
favorite or type of meat and the strip
is my favorite type of steak so uh i
love it you get it i like to sear mine
and do a little butter on top
that's just my way maybe you like to
grill yours i don't know but butcher
butcherbox is ready to give new members
free new york strip steaks for a year
this deal has never been offered before
and it won't last forever get two
delicious 100 grass-fed new york strip
steaks for free in every box you get for
a year
this offer is only available until
november 30th uh 2021 so get it before
it's gone folks that's like uh i think
you got about a day left so do it uh
just go to
butcherbox.com taste buds to sign up
that's butcherbox.com
taste buds to receive this limited time
offer of free new york strip steaks for
a year
folks i got to tell you i love doing
this show but it is hard work sometimes
and when i am done dealing with sal
volcano
i need a break people i need a little me
time i need to go home i need to slip on
some sweatpants and then slide right in
to some comfy slippers and overland has
knocked the slipper out of the park
i've never felt slippers this
comfortable oh my gosh
this the furry goodness of the overland
slipper you don't know what you're
missing people if you don't have one i
put these things on nightly they're i
call them my house shoes i do everything
in my house in my overland slippers
it's it's they're warm they're
comforting and they quite frankly show
me a love and acceptance that most of my
friends including
sal volcano have never shown me so i
urge you to get some of these slippers
overland by the way family owned
it's an american heritage brand that's
put comfort and quality first for nearly
50 years
they offer outerwear they offer
accessories they offer all kinds of
stuff it's not just slippers folks okay
and overland uses expert craftsmanship
to pair the highest quality merino
sheepskin
which is naturally
moisture
wicking temperature regulating and anti
my my my
every time i screw this word up anti
microbot microbials
microbial
you guys know what i mean you're smarter
than me
anyway there's memory foam in the
midsoles and in order
look the slippers they just feel better
they last longer they're just way better
i don't know what else to tell you you
got to get your hands on a pair of these
and if you want a pair of well made
comfortable
comfier than you could possibly imagine
slippers this is your brand these are
the ones to get all right so
don't wait another day to slip into
something way more comfortable get the
best high quality sheepskin slippers on
the market at overland.com
taste buds you're going to get a free
shipping on that order and a free return
okay again it's overland.com
taste buds and i recommend you go today
because these slippers are so beloved
and they've been known to they've been
known to sell out i'm just going to be
honest with you all right that's
overland.com taste buds overland.com
tastebuds
i have remained consistent pimp i have
defended stuffing through and through
and i've [ __ ] on mac and cheese the
entire time look at this gloria
vanderbilt collection right here
i've stayed consistent all right uh
tell me mac and cheese is fun stuffing
is not fun no one's ever been like
excited about stuffing i mean i guess
you have but that's absolutely i have
been at thanksgiving but i know what you
mean mac and cheese brings joy to more
lives more consistently course stuffing
does mac and cheese is is americana i i
know i say that once in a while but mac
and cheese is a staple comfort food
on the american menu it really is and it
makes a nice noise when you plop it down
it sounds like sex it's a little like
it's it's like squishy and nice and warm
it warms up other things you can dip
your stuff into the cheese you can
borrow the cheese from the mac and
cheese for something else you got a
piece of broccoli nobody likes broccoli
you dip it in the mac and cheese now you
got cheese
mac and cheese i'm just curious broccoli
i just said i'm with them that's but
that's it is there a meat you'll eat
with it that you'll be turkey if i get
some cheese on my turkey i'm thrilled if
i get stuffing on my turkey i'm appalled
but you only you eat kraft mac and
cheese with a with like a dinner style
turkey that's right okay that's what we
have at thanksgiving well we're in trash
people
this homemade i'm with you in the
homemade
craft you make it at home you boil it
and then you put the sauce in i will
tell you i do like when you when you
first put it in the powder and the
butter and then you have to
yeah the craft powder cheese oh i'm
talking about the good the deluxe craft
oh okay well that's great too
with the package the deluxe
velveeta has the squeeze similar yes and
they have the shells i really do think
the shells are better because they do
cup the cheese they're like little mini
cheese cups i know about the cup get the
science of that but the shells always
turned me off it always felt the shells
to me always felt like if you went to
like your grandmom's and she was using
what she had in the house to make a mac
and cheese that's the elbow an untenable
uh reply
that's ridiculous
who thinks that all these shells remind
me of when my grandmother was cooking
but she didn't have what she needed and
she took a reach in there and just
pulled down
that is not relatable elbow macaroni is
mac and cheese that's why
i like when you even when you even when
you squeeze it in i do love the process
of you're in the pan and you're making
sure it's yeah
i love that
it's cathartic it's it's comfort it's uh
it's satisfying gratifying and then i
love let's talk about that you know what
i do too i like to when i around four
minutes left in the boil i take the
packet of cheese i put it on the stove
so the heat from the
the fire the flame starts to melt the
cheese gets that cheese nice and heated
it's like goo you want to talk to your
garden that's big if we're going to talk
instance and you want to talk cathartic
i'll talk instance and i'll talk
cathartic stovetop you put the pot down
you boil the water you put the butter in
as soon as that water hits boil and the
butter is melting in it you dump in a
bag
of un-high of dehydrated stuffing mix
and it hits that water and comes
alive fluff it with a meaning over here
come on this is disgusting it actually
just gets bloated with water it because
i actually think you called it stuffing
mix and i think you hit on something
that was gonna work against you i
believe stovetop was first put to market
to be a stuffing additive no it was not
yet
to be the bread
in the ingredients of all the other
stuffing and i think that people were
just like you know what we're fine with
just the bread it has the taste and
you're just eating this is not true
soggy breadcrumbs is all you're eating
when you make it that's what you're
eating it's just nothing makes you right
it's a stuffing you would eat a whole
box of it at night
yeah i did
that doesn't take away from what i
believe to be true in what i just said i
said you've said you want to talk
cathartic instant foods that you can
make the stovetop you put the lid on you
let it sit in the water five minutes you
get it out you fluff it it's it's it's a
great now the fans are chiming in on
joe's side and it seems like they're
saying that there's more nostalgia and
family tied to stuffing than to mac and
cheese absolutely absolutely you imagine
home alone would not have been a hit if
kevin sits down and says a little prayer
in front of a bowl of stuffing
out on this movie it's too violent i
don't care for it
but that's my point
that's my point
when you get through the magazines
quelled the violence in that movie when
you get to when you get to it is true it
is i mean you want to talk about the
foods of an idiot eight-year-old of
course like the mac and cheese but you
want to talk about it
two criminals two psychotic murderous
criminals
in the mcallister house
stuffing's gonna cross the board over
and over again you're hitting all
demographics with stuffing you're
hitting all democrats how are you
calling stuffing and kicking things when
the whole damn campaign is two kids
scheming to eat more breadcrumbs that's
one demographic i'm gonna give you
another demonstration
uh the older folk that want to feed the
grandchildren of stuffing the families
that want to share the stuffing together
for the holiday meal stuffing is also
part of the not just thanksgiving and
holiday cuisine part of the soul food
cuisine you'll find stuffing mac and
cheese baby boy
jump on soul food
soul food i mean stella is [ __ ]
eating mac and cheese out the ass
probably
who yeah she got a groove back
stuffing feels whiter than mac and
cheese you can't talk soul food and say
stuffing's over matters
with mac and cheese then too i'm
agreeing with you first of all i agree
with joe that if you're taking if you
want to talk demographics i will tell
you
16 and under you're getting 100 ratioed
mac and cheese absolutely that's a bold
statement no a kid doesn't like stuffing
i'm 39 i've still never had stuffing i
don't even know what we're talking about
i don't know what stuff you also told us
in a text message that you eat chicken
parm once a day that's right that's wild
let's talk about that for a minute yeah
that text because that's so that was why
i want to i want to quote you correctly
because i i read that and i was like if
this is somewhat true that's that's
pretty that's pretty notable i mean once
a day yeah it's somewhat true i would
say five times a week four or five times
semi daily we talked about it i check
them out almost once a day throughout my
life
yeah well adult life for sure take us
through that big chicken parm family
well it's delicious i mean i have a
serious reflux issue sick of it i don't
reflect too yeah me too i had to go to
the doctor but he said i'm okay okay but
no but you got acidity in the chicken
parm doesn't hurt make your reflux go no
it does that's how good it is i'm
willing to pay the price of fried cutlet
as well doesn't help you sure i may pass
away from esophageal cancer but i'll
live my life to the fullest by eating
chicken parm every day another thing
chicken parm is deceivingly very high in
fat and calories oh is that correct yes
but you're a real sin god love you well
i got some mushy business here but i
don't like business i mean i am mushy
business deceivingly it's fried chicken
with cheese on it yeah but there's the
deception
it's mind-blowing like a chicken parm
entree just two pieces
it's terrible 1300 it's something
terrible for you but wait a second wait
a second so what what
i because i mentioned this on bennington
yesterday
that you eat chicken
harm once a day we were all dumbfounded
we were all discussing it they said in
which fashion i should i can only
imagine it's a delivery of a sandwich of
some kind i can't imagine list is going
to a fine italian restaurant once a day
and sitting down to get a chicken parm
meal so when what favorite chicken parm
is it your fashion are you eating this
well first of all i get it delivered
uh someone's dying back there does a uh
i go to dinos that's not fine it's like
a regular corner place they deliver it i
eat half and then i eat the next half
later that night or the next day so it's
two for what you're saying a platter you
get a platter yeah a bowl of ziti and
sauce sauce and cheese sandwich every
once in a while i'll get a sandwich if
there's a sandwich available i'll get
the sandwich but typically i like a nice
entree i was just in chicago into orso's
they had a great chicken parm okay i'm a
chicken farm guy i think if anyone has
to make a case it's you guys making a
case against eating chicken parmesan two
great chicken parmesan go try it out
please emilio's belotto on houston oh i
went there down to my chicken pot that's
where you recommended before is that
right
i don't know i think i went there uh
quality italian makes what they call a
chicken parm pizza it's for two so it's
a bit pricey and you can't really have
unless you're with a bunch of people but
it's basically this big and they make
the whole thing a chicken parm and it's
it's pretty outrageous that sounds
delightful have you ever had the chicken
parm from the palm
steakhouse
no unreal
unreal i never i took my parents there
once for dinner my mom ordered the
chicken farm and i was like what are you
nuts we're at the palm you get a steak
i took a bite of this thing i was like
holy [ __ ] really i thought about it for
weeks all right maybe i'll go to the
palm i've never seen your menu go to the
go to the palm hills kitchen
and get the chicken parm all right we'll
do it i mean i go to a restaurant i sit
down i look until i find chicken parm
and i put the menu i give it right back
to them really if i can't find a chicken
parm i'll ask them hey could you make a
chicken parm by any chance and they say
no this is a mexican restaurant and i
said i'll see you later right
i mean i love chicken pie i'm all
chicken parm yeah it's a delightful meal
i mean sauce
you're at soup plantation
[Music]
i love chicken parm but i don't you know
well my family's the same way this is
all my parents eat they've never gone to
a restaurant and not ordered a chicken
parm
it's strange because you're an irish
bunch aren't you yeah but uh you know
the irish we don't have our own food
really what do you want us to eat
potatoes and mac and cheese you got your
corned beef oh come on and you want to
eat corn beef chicken farm
but you know i'm just saying
one beef is uh i have it like once every
couple of years and i'm good
that's it yeah
i've had questions
for my life ten times yeah i would say i
would say i had it on the five times
yeah same
really yeah i love corn beef
i feel like i'm gonna have a heart
attack while i'm chewing his arms
as opposed to that light chicken part
no but there's something about the
corned beef it just feels like i love
heavy and fat and it's heavy it's a
heavy meat i mean it's a it's a it's a
heavy meat you deal with yeah now how do
you feel about my cheese pizza only
status uh program you only eat cheese
pizza i only eat cheese pizza and i only
order cheese pizza for a group because
that's what people secretly want how do
you feel about that well unless you're a
vegetarian i think that if there was a
pepperoni and a cheese people are
reaching for the pepperoni they've seen
happen my whole life no you're incorrect
i've seen it my whole life here's what
they'll do though here's what they think
there are people that won't eat
pepperoni because they're like i don't
care for pepperonis but the people that
eat the pepperoni as soon as they're
done with the pepperoni they're going
for cheese slices
outside of pepperoni i think that the
cheese will rain supreme but through and
through people you know people will
order pepperoni and cheese because that
is pleases everyone pepperoni is always
done first you want both some people
want only cheese nobody wants only
pepperoni nobody that eats pepperoni
pizza goes well i will not trust wow
right now could have been cheese pizza
versus pepperoni pizza we could have had
it
i will disagree with you because here's
the thing when i go let's say to a party
yes let's see what we're talking about
you've ordered for all of us yes i've
ordered cheese pizza all right i'm at a
party i've got to watch my intake
there's other people you can't eat
can't be the three slices guy you look
like an animal sure i go for two slices
of the loaded up because i'm like
that'll fill me up with that and then
i'll be good and then i'll move on
i'll let the i let the ladies have the
cheese slices you know but what happened
i guess more to my point is the people
there's always somebody when you're
ordering pizza to group they want a
specialty they go give me a pineapple
where do you have this and what happens
is they have one piece of pineapple and
then they look to my cheese which is all
i eat so i lose my cheese i am kevin
mcallister you are i will i'll agree
with you with that but i'm just saying
the reason that she seems to be the most
popular is because it's the least
offensive
pizza starts at square one with a cheese
pizza so anybody who's adding something
they're already eating the cheese pizza
underneath that so
it's gonna please most people exactly
that's what i'm saying so i get for
ordering for a party but i'm just
talking brass tacks
in front of me not a party just a party
me
cheese and pep i'm gonna take the pup
i mean
i
pizza i like pepperoni pizzas fine so if
you're eating alone and you control the
consumption of the pizza and you're not
worrying about pleasing anyone why don't
you ever vary from a cheese i'm telling
you though what my point is i hear it
everybody sees the cheese they go i'll
have a slice of that i'm gonna try it no
matter how convicted they are i want
pepperoni when they see the cheese
there's still pepperoni left you gotta
go let me get one of those cheese slices
you got to get an extra cheese every
time you get two cheese and then a
couple specialties because everybody is
going to dip into the cheese because
like sal said it's a palette cleanser
i'll tell you this cheese will but i
tried especially leftovers when i try a
new i have two things to say when i try
a new pizzeria i go two two slices i go
plain cheese just to see what they're
made in white and then i'll and then
i'll go with toppings okay because i
want to see what they're made of cheese
right right
i will tell you the biggest waste of
time pizza ever and it infuriates me
when somebody says let's do a veggie
nobody wants the [ __ ] veggie nobody
wants it and you know where else you
show up stuffing that's right
as a matter of fact three of your main
ingredients in your stuffing is veggies
but
veggie pizza is a big difference from
some veggies in the stuff i'm sorry
veggie
oh god veggie pizza is just
it's a waste it's a waste somebody
always insists on a veggie and it nobody
wants it can i tell you where my psyche
went when you talked about the party and
putting out two different pies i
actually feel like i want to take the
non-plane first
because i'm only going to have one
because i don't want to use i don't want
to be greedy and eat all the
stuff the things that have toppings so
i'm always like i'll have one but then i
i don't want to be greedy and take
another one so i'll go to the cheese and
and i see cheese that way and i also see
cheese as a if i'm having three i'll
have a plane at the end just to dismount
you know what i mean all right
so then i could make an argument just
like you could cheese is because i will
say a plain cheese is the true pizza
essence in taste and so i want to when i
want to feel like i had pizza but i'm
having two to three slices i'll eat the
pizza that has like oh this is broccoli
robin sausage and this one here is olive
white and then i'll have the last one
less so then when i feel i feel my body
feels like i don't want to be white what
is with you with the olives yeah who the
hell is ordering it oh
you got to stop white clam there you go
white clams yeah banger pie god what are
you insane no this is terrible a white
clam pie is a
a staple in all pizza reason it's a
banger pot what staple i delivered pizza
for five years i've never seen this ever
this is this is and you also grew up
near the one in the history of the earth
a white clam pizza is on every single
pizzeria's menu every
let's get up right now go two store
fronts down to the pizzeria ask them if
they make a white clamp
i'm with joe on this i've never even
heard of white clam
you know what i'm throwing it because i
don't stand to lose i've never got i
don't know the menu
everybody was that the friday the 13th
music
no i was
telling him
so i don't call the pizza with him
screaming at me hey do you guys make
white clam pies they'll say yes and then
what happens oh do i do a little
thanksgiving they're exciting to me what
to say when i call what happens
you're gonna laugh him off the phone
no you know what you're gonna hear
here's what's gonna happen he's gonna
ask some other guy you're gonna hear
about the white clown
no no white clown you're welcome
hold on hold on one thing this has to be
a pizzeria not a pizzeria that also
sells bagels you said the pizzeria two
doors down is it a pure pizzeria it says
remington pizza okay folks this podcast
is sponsored by better help better help
is a wonderful
wonderful
service uh the the this is a great great
thing they're providing for people
look if there's something interfering
with you and your happiness something
preventing you from achieving your goals
uh you know something that's maybe
preventing you from assessing your needs
whatever it is
better help is here to help
okay they're here to help you do all
these things by matching you with your
own licensed professional therapist you
can start communicating within
under 48 hours i can't stress this
enough and i say it every time
we do a better help spot
the hardest part
and i've i've experienced this my
friends have experienced this it is the
hardest part of trying to get help in
this department is the bureaucratic crap
that you have to go through
people i can't say how many friends have
said to me
you know geez i hear such good things
about therapy but every time i try to do
it
they're not taking new patients and i
can't find anybody in my network and
it's impossible and you're already
feeling overwhelmed or stressed or
anxiety or or depressed or down or what
or scattered whatever it is the last
thing you need now
is
the trials and tribulations of trying to
make this thing work that you're trying
to use to fix your your situation or to
better your situation better help is
here
to do this for you they're here to
streamline the process and let you get
the help you need immediately it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional
counseling and it's done securely online
there's a broad range of expertise uh
all available and and which by the way
some of this expertise might not be
locally available in many areas so
you're getting stuff that you might not
have access to through this service so
listen to me visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds i know we joking these ads a
lot and we try to make them fun and
funny but i can't stress it enough as
somebody who has gone and received these
type of services throughout his life if
you need this if this is something that
you want if this is something that will
help you i'm telling you go to
betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's better help okay that's
how it's spelled and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
here's the special offer by the way for
taste buds listeners you're going to get
10 off your first month can't beat that
betterhelp.com tastebuds that's
betterhelp.com tastebuds we're just
coming out of holiday well we're not
just coming we're coming out of the sec
the first half of the holiday season
we're about to enter the second half
this is where it gets heavy now all
right we're coming out of halloween
candy thanksgiving turkey and all the
sides and we're headed for christmas
which is
candy and turkey again maybe a ham and
all the sides all over again and then
you're hitting new years which is just
you know sugary drinks and maybe a
little candy i don't know a lot of beer
champagne that sort of thing my point is
this people
a lot of people say
after the holidays i'm gonna get into
shape
i don't advise that strategy you got to
stay on top of it you say joe how do i
stay on top of it it's too much to go to
the gym it's too hard to get out of the
house i don't want to pay a gym
membership and i don't use it blah blah
blah blah folks one word
peloton
peloton is the answer you get yourself
one of these pelton bikes you're working
out in your house every day or as much
as you want to
at your own convenience in your own home
all right this is the the problem with
with getting into shape
we're busy we're all busy okay
especially during the holidays then we
think the holidays will end and i will i
won't be as busy no you're gonna be just
as busy because there's other stuff
that's always filling up the dock okay
also that winter malaise that we all
feel when january hits you know
that's not going to help okay what is
going to help
make you it motivated make you feel
motivated is exercise and what's going
to help you do that exercise is making
that exercise within reach peloton is
here to do that for you and that's what
sets them apart from a lot of different
home workout whatever they're bringing
the gym experience into your home there
are classes you can do you can pick the
types of music you want to motivate you
to work out this screen on that bike is
giving you so much good stuff to make
your workout experience fulfilling and
full and and complete and comprehensive
so you don't feel like you're just on
some machine staring at a wall and not
getting what you should be getting out
of the home workout that's the tough
thing about a home workout you're going
am i doing it right am i doing this am i
doing it peloton is here to fix all that
you turn on that screen you subscribe to
certain classes the ones that appeal to
you and they're going to take you
through it just like you're going to a
real gym all right so they're gonna
peloton also making fitness fun and it's
entertaining the workouts don't feel
like a chore you know
i am dying to get my hands on a peloton
bike my buddy sal my co-host sell he's
got one i've used his i've enjoyed it
quite a bit
why do you use sal's bike sometimes i
sleep over cells why do you sleep over
south it's none of your business the
point is is sometimes i wake up at cells
and i use the peloton bike and i have
enjoyed it quite a bit i'm very excited
to get my own uh and the only reason i
haven't yet is because i'm trying to get
things out of my one-bedroom apartment
so i can fit it but that's the other
thing i can tell you well i don't need
to get that much out before i can fit
the peloton bike these things are
compact you can put them almost anywhere
all right this is the thing for you if
you've been trying to motivate into home
working out and you're never alone with
the peloton again you're gonna you can
ride with co-workers if you want you can
ride with friends you can connect with
people you can work out in interest
groups like peloton newbies for instance
or peloton parents or whatever
it's there for you this is it it's all
on the plate you just need to take it up
and eat that delicious workout that
peloton is serving you so
go to onepalatine.com
and learn more okay that's one
peloton.com to learn more you can try
peloton classes for free for the rest of
the year
new members only by the way that's only
for new members visit onepeleton.com at
to learn more terms apply palatine when
your workout is a joy it's a joy to work
out
more like riveting pizza
he's going to consult with somebody
watch
watch here comes a consultation
is that your
speaker it sounds slow
hi how you doing hey do you sell a white
clam pizza
didn't think so thank you
staten island and i worked at a pizza
for five years five stars so you also
grew up next to the only a w in the
eastern seaboard can i just say this he
didn't say like this staten island's
weird white clam pizza the tone wasn't
this oh no we don't sorry he was like
this no he was like don't can call here
again
he reacts look at that this tube it's
pointing at new brunswick and uh maine
there's like two little
white snakes
frank pepe frank pepe invented the white
clam one of the biggest guys in the
pizza game
are you nuts yeah but frank pepe's at
one place name any pizza root they make
pizzeria some [ __ ] that's some
[ __ ]
is that a dollar cheese slice place is
that a dollar cheese slice place no you
know it doesn't have white clam pizza
domino's because it's not a common
domino's not gonna sell seafood
but that didn't there was only two red
things they were in two different states
you know you're looking at these
pepperoni the red little things are all
over the mountain
let's go let's call someone let's call
someone let's call jay let's call big j
no no we're not calling
anyone you you guys are you guys are
living in a waiting
williamsburg pizza one of the best
pizzerias on the lower east side
by the way you owe us 40 dollars
now you [ __ ] told me that i was a
rich man and and i was flaunting my
money and you weren't taking the bag
say that i never said i wasn't taking
the bet yeah i never said i wasn't did i
say it wasn't you
aren't taking the bed no listen to me
listen
you have to pick remington let me pick a
pizzeria i bet you pick any one of them
in new york call everyone
hi how you doing do you sell a white
clam pizza
yeah no
[Music]
where's
also joe did agree to the bet joe list
backed out yeah you owe me 20 i'm sorry
20 by the way i am not saying that yeah
you mean lombardi's in little italy yes
that place i think might have a white
clip why because you think they're a
real deal no but that's not real
because it's in little italy you exact
words where every pizzeria is this i'll
say i swear to god this is not
hyperbolic this is not i've never gone
into a pizzeria that didn't sell a white
clan pie oh that's insane
my balls are blown up no that's not a
picture my balls are blown off my balls
are blown off you got two in a row that
said no i think you should call the
italian place that'll be the nail in the
coffin lombardi's this be three for
three parties will have it though oh
let's see let's see who knows he said
nobody has it hold on that's not what i
said you said every pizzeria has it and
i said that's crazy i would say this i
will make you i think
italy pizza across from umberto's clam
house might have white clamshells don't
call that place joe here's what i'll do
let's get it let's go right now let's
get it right now i will look up the top
10 pizzerias in an article whatever
comes up we will call all 10 of those
pizzerias in new york city and i
guarantee you the majority if not nine
out of ten will have a white clan pie
it's i would have said ten out of ten
until i saw these two people in the navy
it's worth pointing out too that both
were dismissives we got dismissive no's
neither one of them went oh my god we
get this call
you know what i wish you would have said
this is what i wish you would have said
this one but you but you've heard of it
it's common marty says a famous clan pie
as i said okay because it's little italy
no it's because pizzeria outside of
little italy has this
that that's a ridiculous claim buddy
it's ridiculous no but it's you're
taking the argument too far his argument
is that everyone has this right we have
won that argument yes
no you haven't existed
[Music]
the majority are going to have clam the
majority will always rule you got lucky
with those two you picked the first
place you said the pizza place two
blocks down he's just cause i just feel
like i've never seen on staten island
there's not one pizzeria without a clown
there's the there's the thing look up
staten island pizza scissors one without
white clam i'm willing to bet there's a
white clam
list pizza place in staten island
no way that i'll bet on no way
hold on i got 10 bucks that says
somewhere on that entire [ __ ] island
i swear
i'm sorry
come on mac and cheese what that's too
that's ridiculous stuffing's going to
take the fans crashing stuffing really
wow yeah stuffing stinks nobody's
excited about stuffing i feel bad that
we we picked this
it's like you picked it's like we picked
the raiders in tecmo bowl and you got uh
yeah it is true we got jackson yeah it's
ridiculous i mean mac and cheese oh [ __ ]
everybody loves macaroons nobody
people's favorite food can be mac and
cheese myself included possibly that
nobody's favorite food is stuff that's
true
is this staten
doesn't matter what the name of it
[Music]
city how can i help is
number one uh do you have clam do you
have a white clam do you have a white
clam pizza
i'm gonna be very honest this is not
even a restaurant this is just a virtual
marketing number oh okay a friend of
mine said every pizza place on staten
island would have this pizza we were we
you were just the first one we called so
he's obviously an idiot and wrong but
thank you i'll see you later
hey laughs
because that was luxury of forest avenue
pizzeria
how you doing do you have a white clam
pizza
one out of four you got no the pop-up
that he said i need to be honest with
you does not count he was in his [ __ ]
mother's basement actually joe lucius
made a good point we should call up a
pizzeria and ask them what they feel if
it's popular or not that's great i'll
take that any day yeah today i'll take
them and answer us right now of course
what do you mean hey why come by yes or
no let me ask you a question do you
think white clan pie is normal on the
pizzeria's menu they will say yes wait
how did this debate start what did you
say originally that it was uh he said he
orders a white clamp
in the array
in the array of pizzas he gets for a
party and i said white clam and he goes
it's a staple it is
so funny if i had anyone here that was
from the pizzeria culture as i grew up
in
now i grew up in it now we grew up five
years i worked there from from 15
how did you find time when you did seven
years making meatloaf for the deli
i worked at both oh my god 14 to 19 at
the delhi you grew up in the pizzeria 17
to 22. i haven't been serious about your
family
i didn't know you guys had a big
pizzeria business what are you talking
about listen to me guys
the listeners thank you foolish
they think
listeners in ohio don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about that you're
arguing with this much conviction when
we called two pizzerias and they said no
dismissively no not even like oh
[Music]
staples richmond pizza and virginia on
staten island you said every staten
island pizza will have it maybe you're
right i never heard of richmond well
that's weird you're calling [ __ ]
establishments i just put
hi
hi sir how you doing hey do you have a
white clam pizza
i can make a few but but i mean is it on
but is it on your menu i mean
yeah sure
okay thank you and just out of curiosity
would you say that's a common pizza in
most pizzerias or is it more just like a
staten island little italy kind of thing
no i i think i think a white clan pie is
mostly
i know i said an island it is there's a
lot of there's a lot of places that do
have that yeah but the average place in
manhattan or whatever
to get the [ __ ] out of here
well is it on every manhattan beat
series what the [ __ ] is that guy going
to answer you
hold on hold on hold on joe let me take
a little interview for your club
yes it's on fifty percent of manhattan's
menus
this
[Music]
but he didn't say of course he said i
can make it he's going to go out and buy
white no no no no no no no no no no no
you don't want to say no you don't get
how stand out people talk
he's like i guess i can make that for
is it on your menu though and he goes
yeah of course it's on my menu so now
we're two for two and you're trying to
push the guy who's making the pizza this
guy
no this is a sat down thing and it's not
common everywhere else so you call four
pizzerias as far as i'm concerned what
the pop-up that he he confessed he's not
real does not count it's two two it's
two to two your initial argument was not
cool
you're
especially if you're from new york
if you're from new york
this is common everywhere you are in the
golden rule
where i am no no no
no no you said stay put to new york
no no new york city
you're a piece of [ __ ]
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say an
iowa
i don't eat pizza in iowa i eat pizza my
whole life forty something years here
and i don't know you never order pizza
dollars yeah i'll say this i'm going to
start a new bet with you we'll take a
whole episode to do it
i don't want it
i guarantee you it's give me my twenty
dollars of the two of you you're
glistening no glisten you're glitchy i'm
delighted
look at this he's welching he's welcome
welching go ahead [ __ ] twenty dollars
get it out but you should take that 20
and buy a pepperoni pizza a staple
[Music]
all
why don't you send your assistance again
just tens and ones all scraggly
all right you got you got [ __ ] 20
quarters in your pocket
take us to the polls before you go to
the polls you want to conclude your
argument we got we got sidetracked here
so now we're done you don't you're done
you're not going to god
you can admit that stuffing is well
below mac and cheese i will say this in
closing for for a guy that loves cheese
on that noodle so much he really argued
for some goofy toppings added to his
pizzas the white glam you're both crazy
you guys are this is coming from a guy
who self-admittedly after four decades
only eats a cheese pizza he doesn't look
elsewhere he just eats your cheese pizza
here's another guy i got extra sauce
extra cheese extra sauce but you only
eat cheese i'll put some crushed red
pepper you don't even have the scope
of what we're talking about here we go
your blind is on you you walk into a
cheese pizza hello
oh she's sliced that's right you don't
even because i care about everybody i
care about people be a tunnel vision
because i if you order a white clam
nobody wants it listen to me first off
you're gonna want new york places at
least if you're from any of the five
boroughs new jersey long island any new
york any tri-state area who's got
blinders who's got blinders you're
picking an island in america
this is my impression of a couple
driving home from pizza party
south house ready
ready
can you believe that [ __ ] white clam
pizza i didn't know you could put that
in mine i didn't know you could put that
inside hey siri so we gotta wrap it up
seriously
hi siri
we gotta wrap the episode up so we can
have time to do jay's episode properly
three or three he's not even here yet
let's we're wrapping it up
hey buddy are you here yet no right are
you gonna be here any second
uh not any second i mean like in a few
minutes i'm on house no worry no worries
jay can i ask you a question is a white
clam pizza a common pizza in pizzerias
that you would see almost everywhere
more so that they'd even have it on the
menu then a pizzeria wouldn't have it on
the menu yes or no white clam pizza jay
i think in today's world yes thank you
so much i appreciate you i'll talk to
you guys
yeah
i think in today's world you said a
staple
you're acting like white claim is
pepperoni it's not pepperoni it's not
pepperoni i don't think it's pepperoni
it's on the menu
when i delivered in the late 90s it was
not in today's world it was on every
menu that's not today's world i mean
that's been around it's not just today's
world's been around can you admit you're
acting as if white claim is pepperoni i
am not that's how you behave you are
you're behaving that way i do believe
white clam is on way more menu
we got to wrap up guys
from new york
in the comments we have to wrap up all
right you guys are okay yeah jesus
[ __ ] christ 35
yeah stuffing
damn i didn't think stuffing was gonna
lose like that sixty five thirty five
big steaks
i'll tell you stuffing is real a real
powerhouse in context but mac and cheese
is a meal in and of itself year round i
think you lost there because
i started the episode with this not
enough people make stuffing year round
for it to continue
nobody cares and the cases you made
sausage celery onions ugh anyway we're
here by the way just a quick plug we
didn't say it at the top we're here by
the way
in my bar yes uh in sandwich shop joey
roses we're recording from here i
shouted out the we did we talked about
the address everything
was that last episode we're getting oh
yeah in this episode we didn't do it yet
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what
i was saying i thought you didn't you
didn't do it yet today this is called
white clams yeah we're uh we're at my
barn restaurant joey rose's 174
rivington if you're watching this
episode we are now open wednesday
through sunday we open at 12 p.m every
day uh thursday friday saturday we're
open till two
wednesday and sunday we're open till
midnight uh sandwiches
booze
all affordable awesome we're in the rose
room in the back we're in the rose room
in the back it's a social club come
enjoy yourself come enjoy yourself and
follow us on joeyroseshard8 uh on
instagram and twitter joey you got
anything to plug please sure i don't
know which camera to look at i feel like
i'm uh bill belichick over here um yeah
um by youtube go to my youtube i'm
releasing a special in a few months so
please subscribe to my youtube and
december 22nd one night only i'm in
houston secret group oh nice all right
and uh go to savilecountcomedy.com i'm
touring right now so there's
cities everywhere across the united
states and they are active and live uh
like yogurt uh they are on sale and you
can get them there and uh god bless yeah
he won't be eating pizza at any of these
road dates white clam everywhere i go
i'm ordering it from the in the green
room everywhere i go
they won't have it does anyone do the i
love you thing oh yeah
i guess you can do it
we say we say to him now i still love
you and he says i love you too and
that's how we close it out oh i see
because at the end we don't want to
fight like you know anything oh so we
look at him and we say i mean i argued
with both of you yeah do i have to say
it to both of you guys no we you know we
go to him yeah okay
i still i love you i love you too all
right hey
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to them hey kitty
kitties all right do me a favor i want
you to come see me live i'm finally
touring again all the tickets are on
savile countercomedy.com
many more dates will be added you guys
are always screaming at me the dates
they're going to keep being added but
these are the cities i'll be at uh if we
haven't done it yet right december yeah
this is airing thursday december 4th and
5th i'll be at the west palm beach
improv december 10th in boston the chevy
year theater december 11th at the
borgata kind of hometown thing atlantic
city new jersey there's only a few
tickets left for boston ac please get
those that come out december 26 dallas
december 27 san antonio december 28
sugarland aka houston december 29th st
louis december 30th columbus and new
year's eve december 31st cincinnati all
those are with chris d and then my new
data just went up january 14th in des
moines january 15th in indianapolis
january 16th in cleveland january 29th
at foxwoods in connecticut we are adding
a show the first one is basically sold
out february 19th in washington dc
tysons virginia to be announced very
quickly uh next week or this coming week
i will be announcing just so keep a
heads up san diego los angeles
burlington vermont detroit pittsburgh
albany madison and chicago all tickets
savolcano comedy.com uh more cities
being announced i mean it's a mouthful
but i just i need you guys to come out
and see me because it's been so long and
we need to laugh and uh this is casey
jost everybody the earth is flat